voilà
c'est l'algérie qui l'a vu naître mais
c'est lyon qui l'a vu grandir aussi
corps à cheetah romantique avec un zeste
d'émotion au monde si on laisse un petit
bout de france et ses débuts c'était
qu'il ya déjà vingt ans le quart de ces
jours reprenaient alors avec l'ironie
douce amère d'une célèbre chanson
populaire
depuis ça c'est pas con jacuzzi
musicalement nord africaines orientales
aimait beaucoup rock techno c'est bien à
l'inutile vous sent beaucoup plus proche
les chanteurs comme les clashs l'état
mon médicament séraphine cassé dans un
rapide
mais l'enjeu tout l'enjeu de culture
histoire de lui faire découvrir l'autre
côté de la méditerranée histoire ici
gagner mais ça qui me tient pas là mais
dans un pays qui n'a pas d'histoire
d'amour c'est un pays
applaudissements
mais rassure de 10 la wonder avec
l'amour succès cette chanson là c'est
une grande bouche est très vive